Carl jung talked about this phenomena,
he cried phenomenon,
he described as a retrogressive
restoration of the persona and so it's a
complicated idea,
but basically what it means is that
sometimes you take a leap forward and
you learn some things,
but you can't catalyze a new identity so
you try to go back and hide in your old
identity and that actually doesn't work
because while things have changed and
you've learned something and that isn't
who you are anymore,
and so it's like you have to cut part
parts of yourself off in a destructive
manner to fit back into the person that
you were.
Now What happens here is that Pinocchio
escapes from this tyrannical situation
and undergoes this descend into chaos,
but he tries to go back home.
He tries to go back to what he was and
he can't do that anymore.
His father isn't at home anymore,
and so,
so when he goes home,
he finds that there's no home there.
Now this happens to people sometimes.
It's often a shock to them.
So one of the things I've noticed about
Peter Pan type,
I'm going to speak about men here
because I've observed it more in men,
is that they often stay under the thumb
of their father and you think,
well why would someone do that?
Because it means they're subject to the
tyrannical judgment of their father.
They're always concerned about what
their father would think or whether
their father approves of it,
of the and so forth.
And you think,
well that's gotta be an unpleasant place
to be.
Why would you do that?
One of the things that I've suggested to
my clients and to other people sometimes
is that here's a weird little exercise
that you can undertake.
A little thought experiment.
So you have your parents and of course
your parents have friends who are about
their age and maybe some of them are
people you only know peripherally and I
might ask you,
well,
do you care more about what your parents
think?
Then you care about what these
peripheral people who know your parents
think.
And then the answer to that is,
well,
of course.
And then the question that arises out of
that is
why,
I mean,
for someone else,
your parents are the peripheral people
and their parents are central.
Like why is it logical that your parents
make opinion makes any more difference
to you than the appearance,
than the,
uh,
the opinion of some randomly selected
people who are approximately that age.
Why is it the case that you would
consider that they would know more than
someone else?
I mean,
I know they know you better and fair
enough,
but that that's not the point.
And then another point there is that the
degree that your parents opinion about
you matters more than some randomly
selected.
People have approximately the same age.
Young would say,
well,
you haven't exactly separated out the
God,
the image from your parents.
And so you're still under that,
that combination.
It's like a complicated thing to talk
about.
But think about the Harry Potter series.
Harry has two sets of parents,
right?
He's got the [inaudible] parents and
then he's got these like magical parents
that sort of float behind and he should
know the difference between them.
They shouldn't be one in the same,
they're not for him,
and it's like,
well,
you have your parents and you have
nature and culture as parents and you
shouldn't be thinking that your parents
are nature and culture as well.
It shouldn't have final dominion over
you means that you're not an individual.
Yet.
If that's the case.
Freud said,
for example,
that no,
no,
no one could be a man and less his
father had died and young said,
yes,
but that death can take place
symbolically.
Okay,
so there's that part of the idea and
then another part of the idea is one of
the times in your life when you actually
realize that you're an individual is
when you'll go and ask your parents
something and you'll realize they
actually don't know anymore about
what you should do.
Then you do,
and that sucks and that's partly why
people are often willing to maintain a
tyrant slave relationship with their
father.
It's like on the one hand,
you have to be inferior in a
relationship like that.
You know,
you've always got the judge watching
you,
but another hand,
there's always someone who knows what to
do.
There's always someone standing between
you and the unknown that you can go ask,
what should I do?
Well,
at some point you'll realize that the
reason you can't ask that anymore is
because they actually don't know anymore
than you do,
and then that's a pain like that.
That is a symbolic death.
Now it's also when you establish a more
individual relationship with your
parents,
it's at that point that you could
conceivably start taking care of them
instead of the reverse and that's a time
that should come,
but you have to let that image of
perfection go and that exposes you.
Well,
that's what happens here.
You know,
Pinocchio goes home and he wants things
to be the way they were and he wants to
stay under the careful care of the
benevolent father,
but that's no longer possible.
He's past that point and that's why the
father has disappeared and so Japan has
gone off to look for Pinocchio because
he also needs Sun,
but,
but in any case,
the house is abandoned and so then we
see inside the house that everything's
covered with cobwebs and everything's
Gone and Pinocchio and the cricket sit
on the steps and they're very concerned.
First of all,
they wonder where he went so they're
actually concerned that he's gone,
but they also don't know what to do
because there's just no going home.
And so that's also the case that once
you hit a certain point in your
development,
well it's the same thing we already
talked about.
The answers that looking for are not
going to be found in your parents house.
It's as simple as that.
Now you could artificially maintain your
dependency,
but you know,
if you do that for too long,
things get pretty ugly.
So you get pretty stale and you know,
you're like bread that's been on the
shelf for too long.